im niedersächsischen cloppenburg sind
sie mächtig stolz auf ihren bahnhof das
schmucke stück steht für mehr als 100
jahre bahngeschichte und ist komplett
denkmalgeschützt
trotzdem hat die deutsche bahn die
historische unterführung mit beton
verfüllt ohne genehmigung der
zuständigen denkmalschutzbehörde häufig
braucht die bahn ja viel zu lange aber
in cloppenburg war sie entschieden zu
schnell zu betonieren finde ich auch
total krank
bei der bahn ist man ja viele posten
gewohnt ich glaube da haben die meisten
oder kopfschütteln für über dass der
gesamte historische cloppenburger
bahnhof zu dem natürlich auch die
unterführung gehört denkmalgeschützt ist
hätte die bahn wissen müssen denn es
steht ganz groß vorne dran direkt unter
dem db zeichen trotzdem pumpt die
deutsche bahn im herbst 23 ladungen
beton in die nicht mehr genutzte
unterführung laut bahn soll damit der
bereich unter dem gleis stabilisiert
werden aber die ganze aktion ist illegal
im cloppenburger rathaus sind die
zuständigen denkmalschützer entsprechend
sauer
hier handelt es sich um eine zerstörung
eines teiles eines kulturdenkmals
deshalb haben wir als erster schritt ein
strafverfahren eingeleitet gegen die
deutsche bahn bei der bahn will sich
niemand zu dem beton desaster äußern
schriftlich heißt es bitte haben sie
verständnis dass wir zu laufenden
strafrechtlichen ermittlungen nicht
inhaltlich stellung nehmen können
viele cloppenburger halten das vorgehen
der bahn natürlich aber für absoluten
irrsinn
natürlich erwartet erwartet man ja von
jedem bürger oder von jeder organisation
dass sie sich an gesetze hält auch von
der bahn
selbstverständlich wird beton einfüllen
es einfach das rausholen es schwer und
wird eine menge arbeit an
aber genau das verlangt die stadt jetzt
von der bahn
der illegal verbaute beton muss wieder
aus der unterführung raus denn die stadt
plant sogar den tunnel zu verlängern für
eine direktere verbindung quer durch
cloppenburg